ام
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تباينت ردود
الافعال في مصر بشان توجيه وزير الدفاع
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح السيسي نداء مباشرا
للشعب المصري بالخروج في مظاهرات يوم
الجمعه المقبل ومطالبته ما سماه تفويضا
لمواجهه الارهابيين كما قال واثار خطاب
سياسي تساؤلات بحديثه عن زاها في
الانتخابات ودعوته المؤسسات الدوليه
للاشراف عليها
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
لوجه في الاستنتاجات التي رات في خطاب
سياسي دليلا على هيمنه المؤسسه العسكريه
الرسائل التي حملها تصدي وزير الدفاع
المصري لشؤون من اختصاصات الرئيس ورئيس
الحكومه
اذن فقد دعا وزير الدفاع المصري الفريق
اول عبد الفتاح السيسي من سنهم المصريين
الشرفاء الى النزول الى الشوارع يوم
الجمعه المقبل لمنحه تفويضا لضرب ما سماه
الارهاب المحتمل على حد تعبيره وقد اثار
خطاب وزير الدفاع المباشر الى الشعب هذا
الخطاب المباشر الى الشعب والذي تحدث فيه
ايضا على الانتخابات المقبله اثار تساؤلات
عن دور المؤسسه العسكريه في حكم مصر
رسميا لمصر رئيس مؤقت وحكومه ادت اليمين
ومن اعضائها عبد الفتاح السيسي بصفته
وزيرا للدفاع امام الرئيس ورئيس الحكومه
لكن السياسي صنع الحدث اليوم بمخاطبته
الشعب المصري والعالم بنفسه ومباشره في
شؤون لا تخص وزاره الدفاع
واطلب من المصريين طلب
يوم الجمعه الجايه
يوم الجمعه الجايه لابد من نزول كل
المصريين الشرفاء
العملاء
ينزلوا
ينزلوا عشان الدين وتفويض و
ام
اني اواجه
العنف والارهاب المحتله
بدا السياسي اشبه بالسياسه الذي يوجه شؤون
البلاد كثير خطابه المباشر الى الشعب
تساؤلات عن تصديه لشؤون من قبيل محاوله شد
الجماهير وطلب التفويض منها والبعد بنزاهه
الانتخابات المقبله بدل ان يقوموا بذلك
الرئيس المؤقت بنفسه او رئيس حكومته طالما
انها شؤون سياسيه مباشره كما يثير خطاب
السيسي اسئله من مفردات المثل الارهاب
وماذا يقصد به تحديدا الهجمات على الجيش
في سيناء فقط من الرافضين عزل مرسي كذلك
في البلدان الاخرى يحكمها العسكر وراء
واجهه مدنيه لا يخاطب المسؤولون العسكريون
الشعب مباشره بليتر كذلك رئيس الجمهوريه
والمسؤولين المعنيين
تبقى تساؤلات اخرى عما دفع وزير الدفاع
الى اللجوء الى مخاطبه الشارع بنفسه
ومباشره دليل ثقه في النفس في استجابه
الجماهير ا مقارنه ضعف في موقفه وفق وصف
قاده الاخوان المسلمين عداد الحشود لن
يتوقف قريبا في مصر وقد تكون جمعه السادس
والعشرين من يوليو بالذات الاكثر ترقبا
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفينا من القاهره
اللواء محمود زاهر الخبير في الشؤون
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه ومحمد الدماطي
وكيل نقابه المحامين المصريين ونائب رئيس
المجلس القومي لحقوق الانسان مرحبا ب
ضيفينا الكريمين
اللواء محمود زاهر بغض النظر عن مضمون
خطاب السيسي هل يحق لوزير الدفاع ان يتوجه
مباشره الى الشعب خطاب وهل يملك اصلا ان
يخاطب الشعب
اولا بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم تحتمل حضرتك
اه في حاله ال الحالات العاديه حينما تكون
هناك حكومه ورئيس دوله وبرلمان
معروف اه موقع وزير الدفاع كوزير من ضمن
تشكيل الحكومه ولكن في هذه الحالات اللي
تمر بها مصر اذا تم تفويض وزير الدفاع من
قبل رئيس الجمهوريه الذي يملك التشريع
ويملك السلطه ثم يؤكد على ذلك بتفويض كامل
من الشعب فهذا تفويض خاص يلزم المرحله
التي تمر بها مصر وهذا قانوني وهذا دولي
وهذا تم العمل به كثيره لكن لكن هناك الان
الرئيس المؤقت اسمه صادق هناك رئيس حكومه
البلوي وهناك حكومه قد تشكلت والرجل هذا
فتح السياسي لم يتحدث عن تفويض من الرئيس
قبل ان يتوجه الى الشعب بل كان يتحدث بشكل
مباشر وكانه يتحدث كوك انه رئيس الدوله
مباشره الى الشعب
الحقيقه فانا شايف انه ربما حضرتك من
الجزء من الخطاب واضح تماما وقد ذكر
بالحرف الواحد انه فاتح رئيس الجمهوريه في
الامر وعرض عليه هذا الامر تفصيلا واخذ
موافقه وتاكيد بل ترحيب شديد من رئيس
الجمهوريه بهذا التفويض اما بالنسبه
للحكومه
ان لم تقف بعد على قدميه وانا اتمنى لها
هذا وبالتالي التوقيت داهمنا وهذا مستقبل
شعب الامر ما شي طبيعي اخذ خالد الفرنسي
في اول في التفويض من رئيس الدوله ثم ليس
عندنا مجلس الشعب هو ذهب للشعب بالكامل
مباشره
وبالتالي اصبح الامر ديمقراطي
وقانوني من مجلس الشعب بكامل وليس من
مندوبين ثم من رئيس الدوله حتى تقف
الحكومه على اقدامها وتؤدي اطوارها كل في
قطاع الاستاذ محمد الدماطي الرجل اخذ
تفويض
من اه اه
قبل ان يتوجه الى الشعب من حيث المبدا هل
هذا مقبول
هل تراه انت اه شيئا يعني امرا عاديا
طبيعيا في هذه الظروف
فنحن كرجال قانون ننظر الى اي دعوه مقاومه
او الى اي امر من الناحيه الشكليه
والناحيه الموضوعيه بالنسبه للناحيه
الشكليه في خطاب الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
السيسي هو ليس له صفه ولا مصلحه في ان
يقوم بالادلاء بهذا الحديث مباشره
لكن واقع الامر انه هو الرئيس الفعليه
سيدي واقع الحال في مصر انه لا يوجد لرئيس
دوله ولا رئيس وزراء الحاكم الفعلي بعد
يوم ثلاثه سبعه هو الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
السيسي فهو ياخذ هذه الصفه فعلا هو تحدث
بصفته رئيسا للدوله المصريه هذا من
الناحيه الشكليه الامر الثاني هو تحدث عن
انه يرغب في مواجهه الارهاب الارهاب عندنا
في قانون العقوبات صدر له القانون رقم
سبعه وتسعين لسنه اثنين وتسعين وهو يعرف
قانون الارهاب والعقوبات التي يتعين اه ان
ينالها هذه ال العصبه التي تقوم بالارهاب
وبالتالي هو ليس في حاجه الى تفويض اذا
كان هناك ارهاب بل هو يكون متقاعد ان لم
يحارب الارهاب هو في الاساس ليست ليست
سلطته وليست وظيفته هو ان يحارب الارهاب
الذي يحارب الارهاب في الاساس هو وزاره
الداخليه باعتبارها هي الجهه المنوطه
بمحاربه الارهاب ان وجد اما اذا كان هذا
الحديث ينسحب الى المتظاهرين فى رابعه
العدويه او في ميدان نهضه مصر
فهذا امر اخر اذا اراد ان يعرف هؤلاء
الشرفاء الذين يؤكدون على شرعيه
الشرعيه الدستوريه وعلى عوده الرئيس مرسي
اذا كان يريد ان يسميهم ارهابيين فهذا امر
اخر يخص الفريق او العبد طيب يعني
نحن امام نحن امام امر جلل نحن امام امر
جلل اقول انه اخر الحلقات في سلسله
الاجهاز على صوره خمسه وعشرين يناير التي
بدا الايجاز الفعلي لها في ثلاثين يوليا
وفي ثلاثه سبعه
اريد فقط ان نحدد يعني اطار نقاشنا نقاشنا
لا اريد ان اخوض في الدلالات والمضامين
الان فقط انا اتحدث عن الجانب الشكلي
تحديدا لان اه
توجه الى الشعب
اللواء
اللواء محمود زاهر
المشكله
طيب تسمعني الان يعني اه
بالنسبه يعني تركيزنا على مساله الشكل
الشكل الخطاب
الرجل وزير الدفاع في حكومه وهناك رئيس
الدوله ويفترض ان مخاطر الامن القومي من
يحددها هو رئيس الدوله وبالتالي هي من
صلاحيات رئيس الدوله بعد ان يستمع الى نصف
وارشادات وتوصيات وتقديرات الاجهزه
المختصه وهو من يقرر في التحسيس من اين له
هذا الحق حتى يتحدث ويحدد هذه المخاطر
شوف حضرتك خلينا نتكلم بكلام علمي وكلام
موضوعي بعيد عن اه
ان الانسان بيحاول يعبر عما بداخله او عن
ذاتيته او عن تطلعاته ويسمى هذا القانون
انا عندي حاجه اسمها امن قومي مصري وانا
افهم في هذا جيدا وافهم محاوره و افهم كيف
هي المسؤوليه على القوات المسلحه المصريه
قبل الداخليه في حفظ الامن القومي المصري
التي منه الارهاب ومنه ما يسمى ب اعتصامات
لرجال شرفاء ولا ادري من اين هم شرفاء وهم
يستعملون السلاح والقتل يوميا امامنا
ومشهود ومستندات يروح للمحكمه انا امام
مرحله الامن القومي لا تتحمل اللغه في
كلام ومن شان
يتكلم و يلغوا اما انا كقوات مسلحه مصريه
مسؤول عن الشعب المصري مشيت الطريق السليم
احترمت رئيس دوله الاستاذ محمد الدماطي لم
يحترم وجوده لا احنا بنحترم رئيس محكمه
دستوريه تحتل موقع رئيس جمهوريه حاليا
فتره انتقاليه تم استئذان
وعرض الامر عليه ثم ذهبنا الى الشعب لناخذ
رايه وقال سياسي بالحرف الواحد المطلب
اذا الشعب المصري الامر بان اللي موجود في
او ما يسميهم الاستاذ محمد متظاهرين نجلس
معهم كيف ما يؤمن الشعب
لم يتحدث عن الشان كله تحدث فقط
وصفهم بالشرفاء وخاطبهم وقال انا قد طلبت
مني واستجابته لكم سابقا يعني وكان يحدد
شريحه محدده شاركت في ثلاثين يوم في
مظاهره ثلاثين انه فقط
وهذا كلام منطقي طبيعي انا اؤيد وحضرتك
واقول
ولا وليس كل الشعب الاندفاعه العدويه ناس
احترمهم ناس مصريين ولكن طلب منهم داخل
القانون القانون يطبق عليهم ما يحمي الشعب
المصري من عن فهم ا وارهابهم او بلطجيته
هذا ما افهموا في اطار الامن القومي
المصري وفي اطار تطبيق ديمقراطيه على
الارض وليست بالكلام وخلال التلفزيونات اه
اه اه محمد الى اي حد ان هذا الخطاب اه اه
يعني يحدد او اذكى صحه ما قال البعض بان
ما جرى في ثلاثين يونيو او ثلاثه هو
انقلاب على الشرعيه هل ربما هذا يزيد هذه
المقوله شرعيه ودقه
هو طبعا الخطاب يؤكد على ان هناك
انقلابا على الشرعيه والحقيقه انا كليه
تسميه و توصيف اخر هو ان ما حدث يوم ثلاثه
سبعه هو بالضبط العامل الحاسم في الاجهاز
على صوره خمسه وعشرين يناير تعلم جيدا ان
الثوره المضاده هي حركه ناقصه بكافه
واصابه اي حركه مرتده الى الوراء ترغب في
بعث النظام الذي ولازم انه هذا هو التعريف
الحقيقي للثوره المضاده وعندما نطبق هذا
على مجرى المشهد السياسي الان بدءا من
ثلاثين يونيو واصطناع هذا الخروج المبهر
الذي قال عنه الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
السيسي انه خروج مبهر وكان يغدق عليه عن
طريق الطائرات في الوقت ال الذين كانوا في
الطرف الاخر هؤلاء كانوا يتم تصويرهم لكي
يتم اعتقالهم هذا هو التوصيف الحقيقي
فمعنى ذلك اننا بصدد الاجهاز على صوره
خمسه وعشرين يناير والمشهد موجود كله سواء
المشهد المحلي او الاقليمي او الدولي انا
اقول بصراحه شديده ان الارهاب معروف
الارهاب تمثل في المجزره البشريه التي
وقعت امام الحرس الجمهورى الارهاب تمثل في
هؤلاء الذين قتلوا سيدات ابرياء في
المنصوره
هذا هو العراقيين
يعني محور حلقتنا سنبحث في الجزء الثاني
نناقش اه اه اه مغزى خوض الفتاح السيسي في
قضايا اه من اختصاص رئيس الدوله والحكومه
سنبحث ذلك بعد هذا الفاصل مشاهدينا ابقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش موقع المؤسسه العسكريه في حكم مصر
من خلال مخاطبه وزير الدفاع عبد الفتاح
السيسي بشكل مباشر الشعب المصري اه مرحبا
ضيفينا الكريمين مره اخرى محمود زاهرمحمود
زاهر محمد الدماطي احمد اللواء احمد اه
زاهر محمد ظاهر هناك من راى في خطاب
السيسي دليلا على عدم ثقته في قدره مؤسسه
الرئاسه والحكومه الانتقاليه على التصدي
لمهمه اقناع الناس بالخروج للتظاهر ب
وبالتالي يعني اه اضطر ان يخاطب الشعب
بشكل مباشر وان يطلبها كما تقول انت
التفويض من من الرئيس
لا يفهم الكلام دا كلام اه مع احترامي
الشديد لكل من يقول وله الحق ان يقول وله
الحق ان يكتب كتاب الارحام مع احترامي
الشديد لا انا اتكلم على واقع و حينما
نتحدث على واقع تعلمنا استراتيجيه باسمه
على ذات واقعي على الارض خمسه وعشرين
يناير شعب
شعب ما زال موجود ما كانت مش الخطه اما
يحب تكلم حد على الصوره يبقى الشعب اللي
كل اي حد يتكلم بيروح تخالف
يكتب كتاب في هذا ولكن واقع الارض يقول ان
الشعب هو السيد قضاء على الارض خمسه
وعشرين يناير وامتدادها في صوره الثلاثين
يوم الاحترام السيد رئيس الجمهوريه المؤقت
في مكانه طبيعي على الواقع وفي خطاب
الشعب المصري لماذا لم يخطو بشكل مباشر
لماذا لم يصادق ولماذا فوسي
هذا يرجع على رئيس الجمهوريه حضرتك تستطيع
تساله في منتصف ولما تصف
والوضع النهار ده الشعب المصري تعرض للقتل
والفوضى من
يعني عامل الثقه وعدم الثقه هذه مساله
صلاحيات هي من صلاحيات الرئيس
والشخص ال ال ال المخول قانونيا ودستوريا
بان يخاطب في قضايا كبرت هذه وليس وزير
الدفاع
وكلام حضرتك سليم وفق سناو كلام منطقي
فاذا كان صاحب الصلاحيات وال مفاوض في انه
يؤدي هذا القرار من حقه تفويض من يشاء وقد
فوض وزير الدفاع في هذا الامر ووزير
الدفاع ذهب الى الشعب ليؤكد ان هذا قرار
ديمقراطي لم ياتي فقط من مندوبين يمثل
ومجلس تشريعي ولكن من المجلس التشريعي
الاساسي وهو الشعب المصري اذا فوضوا طمان
او تصديق او مصادقه على ما صدق به رئيس
الجمهوريه ليس عندي اي بلا قانوني ولا ولا
سياسي
ليس ايضا ان ان يفوض الرئيس ولا مجلس
الوزراء وزير الدفاع تحدث الى الشعب يقول
محمود زاهر اين المشكله
يعني هو ال اه الاستاذ محمود ظهريه تحدث
كيفما شاء لكن احنا يعني المستقره عليه ان
الذي يمثل الدوله المصريه الا على فرض ان
هناك رئيس دوله هو السيد رئيس الدوله
المستشار عدلي منصور هو الذي يتحدث الى
الشعب المصري هو المنوط به ان يتحدث لا
بنسميها في القانون صاحب الصفه من له
الصفه في الحديث هو ال ال ال الرئيس
لمنصور وبالتالي الناحيه الشكليه مفقود
الامر الاخر هو يفوضه في ماذا انتم فوض
اذا كان من القضاء على الارهاب انت مفوض
بموجب القانون رقم سبعه وتسعين لسنه اثنين
وتسعين الاعر في الارهاب وعرفوا العقوبات
وبالتالي لم يكن في حاجه الى تفويض الذي
حدث هو محاوله لجر هذا الشعب الى التطاحن
بين فئتين
وهذه القسمه ليست حديثه
نبقى في جانب الشكل كما قلت من بدايه
الحلقه
العبد المنصور هو صاحب الصفه قانونيا
لماذا خرج السياسي في كلمه الى الشعب
انا من وجهه نظري ان الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح السيسي يستشعر تماما انه هو الذي
اوجد رئيس الدوله المؤقت وانه يستطيع ان
يتحدث في اي وقت وان يتجاوز هذه الحدود
ويتحدث باسم رئيس الدوله ويتحدث باسمه كما
لو كان هو رئيس الدوله
اننا بصدد الان حكومه عسكريه
يحكمها الفريق اول عبد الفتاح السيسي لا
يمكن ان نضع رؤوسنا في الرمال ونقول اننا
ان هناك رئيس دوله مؤقت ووزاره تصور سيدي
ان هذه الوزاره عندما تجتمع لاول مره لاول
مره يكون جدول اعمالها هو الغاء المجلس
القومي لحقوق الانسان
واعاده تشكيل والمجلس الاعلى للصحافه
هذا هو الاقصاء الحقيقي
ان هناك محاوله للمصالحه
اللواء محمود زاهر يعني هذا الخطاب الذي
سمعناه اليوم ل اه ال فريق اولاد فتح سيسي
ايضا السياسي نفسه والمؤسسه العسكريه في
خريطه الفعل السياسي المصري الان
اولا اه بعدها للمره الثانيه غير مسموح
للاستاذ محمد اسمح لي بهذا ان يهين رئيس
الدوله
لم يبقى الا
وهو رئيس دوله لمرحله انتقاليه
السلطات وكامله عندي وزاره ليست وزاره
عسكريه على الاطلاق ومعرفه كان الدكتور
الببلاوى
ولا حدا
عن هذا الكلام وزير الدفاع هو وزير دفاع و
مسؤول مسؤوليه كامله عن الامن القومي
المصري واخذ تفويض بهذا وناقش رئيس الدوله
الذي لم لك السلطات والقرار ثم لجا
والاثنين بتفويض من رئيس الدوله الى الشعب
سيد قراره ليحكم
كما قال الفريق اول السيسى اذن هنا الفريق
اول السيسى ب يضع نفسه في مكانه الطبيعي
والمخول بحمايه الامن القومي تحت امر رئيس
الدوله ثم تحت امر الشعب المصري اه اه
اعيد السؤال نفسه اه لكم ما موقع بعد هذا
الخطاب ما هو الموقع الذي تراه انت اليوم
التحسيسي والجيش في المشهد السياسي المصري
يعني ارجو ارجو من سياده الفريق السيسي
انه يرى المشهد جيدا وان يتراجع عن هذا
الخطاب لانه يضر الوطن الى الخراب الامر
الاخر انه ليس منوطا به الحديث الى الشعب
المصري وان صاحب الصفه الاصليه هو رئيس
الدوله الذي يتحدث الى الشعب المصري الامر
الاخر انه غير صحيح انه جاء بناء على
دستور كما قال الاستاذ محمود الزهار لان
البيان الذي تلاه الفريق او الفتاح السيسي
يوم ثلاثه سبعه كان قد عطل الدستور
وبالتالي هو لم ياتي بناء على الدستور اذن
هذا المشهد ارجو من المؤسسه العسكريه بكل
قياداتها ان تراجع نفسها وان هذا الخطاب
بالفعل في منتهى الخطوره
ولا ادري من الذي نصح ب بهذا الى الفتره
الاخيره من منكم ضيفي الكريمين
بعد هذا الخطاب ماذا تتوقع
محمد هل طريق اخير حضرتك في هذا الامر نحن
لا نحتسب اي شيء لا يمت للواقع بصله
نحن من الاراء نحترم حتى الراي الشاذ
الخارج عن اطار
ولكننا لا ناخذ الا بالواقع توقعاتك بعد
الخطاب باختصار
توقعاتها اليوم
السياسه العسكريه هي ما يحدث ان شاء الله
طيب
يا سيدي هناك تفويض ين متناقضين ولا يصح
ان يقال هذا اطلاقا تفويض من هنا ثم تفويض
اخر ضد هذا التفويض هذا لا يصح انا رايي
ان الفريق او الفتاح السيسي سيراجع نفسه
جيدا لانه يرى ان هذا الخطاب يعني يدفع
بهذا الوطن الى منزلق خطير
نرجو ان شاء الله
شكرا لك محمد
وكان نقابه المحامين المصريين وهو نائب
رئيس المجلس القومي لحقوق الانسان كما
نشكر اللواء محمود زاهر الخبير في الشؤون
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه
وبهذا تحييد الحلقه من الكرام شكرا
لمتابعتكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]